Hello and welcome back to the next module of the operating systems course. And
this module is on system recovery. System
crashes can happen due to power failure,
hardware, and software failures. As operating system
designers, it is essential to understand how
to build systems that can survive crashes.
In this module, we will discuss technologies
that will help us deal with system failures and recover from them. In this
module, we will cover three systems. The first one, LRVM suggests providing a
persistent virtual memory layer in support
of system services. The second one RioVista,
suggests how such a persistent layer can
be implemented in a performance conscious way,
with some ingenuity. The third one,
Quicksilver, suggests a more radical approach.
Making recovery a first class citizen in the design of operating systems.